ANY TIME SOON.
>> THANK YOU.
>> IT IS COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE FOR EITHER THE
GOVERNMENT OR THE PRIVATE
SECTOR TO IMPOSE UPON YOU THE
REQUIREMENT THAT YOU SHOW PROOF
OF VACCINE TO JUST SIMPLY BE
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN NORMAL
SOCIETY.
>> Bill: THAT’S THE GOVERNOR OF
FLORIDA RON DESANTIS SLAMMING
THE IDEA OF A VACCINE PASSPORT
THAT COULD ALLOW BUSINESSES AND
EVENTS TO VERIFY YOU HAVE BEEN
GIVEN THE VACCINE.
THE CONCEPT RAISING A RED FLAG
ABOUT GOVERNMENT OVERREACH.
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT WITH
FORMER GOVERNOR CHRIS CHRISTIE.
WELCOME TO OUR PROGRAM.
IT HAS BEEN SOME TIME.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
TO SET UP THE ARGUMENT THIS WAY.
"WASHINGTON POST" VACCINE
PASSPORTS ARE ALREADY TURNING
INTO A CULTURE WAR.
VACCINE PASSPORTS ARE THE NEW
MASK DEPENDING WHERE YOU ARE,
WHAT YOU READ AND HOW YOU VOTE.
EITHER THE BADGE OF THE
OPPRESSOR OR THE BRAND BORN BY
THE RIGHTEOUS.
THEY WILL EITHER SOLVE
EVERYTHING OR NOTHING.
HOW DO YOU SEE IT, GOVERNOR?
>> LOOK, I THINK THIS IS MUCH
TOO IMPORTANT A PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUE FOR US TO BE PLAYING
GAMES WITH SOMETHING LIKE A
VACCINE PASSPORT.
WHAT WE SHOULD BE WORKING ON IS
GETTING PEOPLE THE INFORMATION
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO FEEL
COMFORTABLE BEING VACCINATED.
THERE ARE LOTS OF PEOPLE THAT
HAVE LOTS OF QUESTIONS ON THERE.
THEY’RE VALID ONES AND WE
SHOULD BE WORKING HARD TO MAKE
SURE WE ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS.
ANY OF US WHO HAVE HAD COVID
AND BEEN VACCINATED THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY AND THIS DISCUSSION
OF VACCINE PASSPORTS AND ALL
THE REST OF THAT JUST SOUNDS TO
ME LIKE ANOTHER IDEA OF BIG
GOVERNMENT RUN AMUCK.
WHAT WE NEED TO BE WORKING ON
IS MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE STAY
HEALTHY SO THAT WE CAN GET
LIVES COMPLETELY BACK TO NORMAL
HERE IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Dana: WHAT DO YOU THINK THE
GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO DO TO GET
PEOPLE TO WANT TO GET THE
VACCINE.
PFIZER’S VACCINE IS 100%
EFFECTIVE FOR 12 TO
15-YEAR-OLDS.
>> WELL DANA, LISTEN, IT’S
ABOUT GIVING PEOPLE THE FACTS.
FIRST OFF ABOUT HOW RANDOM THIS
DISEASE IS.
AS YOU KNOW, I GOT IT LAST
OCTOBER AND WHAT WAS SUPPOSED
TO BE THE SAFEST PLACE IN
AMERICA, THE WHITE HOUSE WHERE
I WAS GETTING TESTED EVERY DAY
WHEN I ENTERED THE GATES AND
TESTED NEGATIVE AND THREE DAYS
AFTER I LEFT THE WHITE HOUSE
WOUND UP ALONG WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND HOPE HICKS AND
KELLYANNE CONWAY HAD COVID.
PEOPLE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THERE
IS NO PLACE THAT’S SAFE FROM
COVID.
SECOND, MAKE SURE THEY
UNDERSTAND HOW RANDOM IT IS
ONCE YOU GET IT.
NO MATTER WHAT YOU’VE READ
ABOUT IT PEOPLE DON’T
UNDERSTAND ENOUGH ABOUT THIS
DISEASE TO PREDICT IT WITH
CERTAINTY.
FOR ME I HAD A 62-YEAR-OLD
COUSIN AND HER HUSBAND BOTH IN
GOOD HEALTH, ONE OF THEM A LONG
SHOREMAN ON THE NEW JERSEY
DOCKS WORKING IN A PHYSICAL JOB
EVERY DAY, BOTH GOT COVID AND
FOUR WEEKS AGO THEY BOTH PASSED
AWAY.
SO WHEN YOU GET IT, YOU DON’T
KNOW WHAT IT IS GOING TO DO TO
YOU.
SO WHAT THE VACCINE IS, WHICH
BY THE WAY HAD FOUR TIMES THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE NORMALLY GOING
THROUGH A CLINICAL TRIAL TO
MAKE SURE IT WAS SAFE.
WHEN PEOPLE HEAR THAT IT MOVES
THEM AND THEY KNOW NOW THAT NO
ONE HAS DIED FROM THE VACCINE.
NO SERIOUS SIDE EFFECTS FOR
ANYONE FROM THE VACCINE AND
LIKE PUTTING YOUR SEAT BELT ON
WHEN YOU GET IN THE CAR.
IT DOESN’T GUARANTEE THAT YOU
WON’T GET SICK BUT IT MAKES IT
MUCH LESS LIKELY THAT YOU GET
VERY SICK OR DIE FROM THIS IN
THE SAME WAY THAT PUTTING ON A
SEAT BELT MAKES IT MUCH LESS
LIKELY.
>> Bill: IT IS A FASCINATING A
ANSWER.
THANK YOU FOR OFFERING THAT.
A QUICK CLIP YOU ARE INVOLVED
IN A PSA TO ENCOURAGE THE
VACCINE WITH GOOD REASON BASED
ON THAT LAST ANSWER.
A QUICK LOOK HERE.
>> COVID-19 HAS CHANGED HOW WE
EXPRESS OUR FAITH AND GATHER TO
WORSHIP.
WE ALL WANT TO GET BACK TO HOW
WE PRAY.
>> Bill: BEFORE YOU GO, HOW DO
YOU THINK THIS ADMINISTRATION
AND THIS PRESIDENT IS DOING?
>> LOOK, I THINK HE IS DOING
WHAT EVERY DEMOCRATIC
ADMINISTRATION IN THE LAST 30
YEARS HAS DONE, WHICH IS WHEN
THEY GET A SMALL BIT OF POWER,
THE VERY NARROW MARGINS THAT
THEY HAVE IN THE HOUSE AND
SENATE, THEY OVERREACH AND THEY
DO THINGS THAT ARE WELL BEYOND
WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO WANT THEM TO DO.
1.9 TRILLION SPENDING PROGRAM,
NOW THIS MOVE TO RAISE TAXES
AND HAVE A BIGGEST TAX INCREASE
IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
THESE TYPES OF OVERREACHES ARE
WELL BEYOND WHAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN SAID HE WAS GOING TO DO
IN THE CAMPAIGN.
I’M STILL SEARCHING FOR THE
BIPARTISANSHIP AND TOGETHERNESS
THAT THE PRESIDENT SAID HE WAS
GOING TO BRING.
SO RIGHT NOW I’M VERY SKEPTICAL
ABOUT WHAT IS HAPPENING IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND DISAPPOINTED
AS I THINK MANY AMERICANS ARE
THAT HE IS NOT TRYING THE
COUNTRY TOGETHER AND FORM
CONSENSUS.
INSTEAD HE IS GOING TO THE FAR
LEFT.
A LOT OF THINGS YOU’VE SEEN HIM
DO IS WAY TO THE FAR LEFT.
>> Bill: THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND HOPE YOU COME BACK